holy moses it is time
to cross through the red sea
into
moonette episode two easter eggs
breakdown from the rockstars
easter egg territory and there's your
rhyme we have
our epic hero shop shirts i even got
more in the closet there is one that i
do not own
john i call dibs i don't care what it is
ha yeah
really losing on this one i'm gonna go
buy a t-shirt
in your face
congratulations
uh leave a like
and
get ready to join us
commenting
it's done let's go
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 2 in which moon knight
narrowly escapes a bunch of vegans by
killing their dog this episode was
filled with easter eggs subtle cinematic
details and you were right about that
so let's break down this shot by shot
for everything that you might have
overlooked
got one guys
that shirt that shirt happens
that's a great shirt dibs all the way
dibs dip dibs it's called tomb of the
moon guide it looks awesome and when you
get it you'll unlock the added option
wait do i have that in a custom
you're not allowed to wear it if you do
because it's mine now
no twinsies it's a real rage beat down
on that jackal that ended last episode
here it echoes
as we hear this because we're staring at
the sand around his bed and the fact
that that sand is intact means that
someone returned home after that fight
and reset the sand that someone being
mark if it's now steven awaking from it
thinking it was a dream so mark is
complicit in keeping stephen in this
illusion that he's just sleepwalking
last episode i pointed out how stephen's
inaugural step in that sand compared
with harrow's first step on glass makes
steven more connected to the sands of
egypt and this episode ends with mark
back in the desert from sand we begin
and to sand we shall return but stop
that's a good book
steps he springs out of bed slips on the
sand stumbles landing on his face just
like he landed in the alps after mark
had been in control it seems like steven
is going to repeatedly land on his face
just like this also his foot he's going
to have a broken jaw it's like he is
being leashed to the bed what was meant
to be a harness for a sleepwalking alter
ego is really confining himself now
among the stack of books in front of him
is one titled adventures of the soul
journeys through the physical and the
spiritual dimensions this is a real 2014
book by a medium named james van praagh
about the human soul and how it fits
into this life and how it travels in the
spiritual realm so really stephen isn't
totally unfamiliar with a soul's
detachment from the physical body
interesting in this last episode but
among stephen's textbooks are a book
about asgard what's new again another
one about wakanda which is
which is derived from the egyptian
feline deity of bastet dude just when i
thought we finally had an mcu show that
wasn't connected to the mcu all that
much oh now they're definitely both
going to show up and take control of the
show i know we're going to have it's
going to be
coming there you go oh sure
you go first we were in a rush
rush to the improv there's a
thoroughfare
improv
and also the key dip prop is good
listening skills good listening
are my favorite stephen opens his
cabinet mirror to confront mark you're
there
didn't think so now it might just be the
way the camera or the cabinet moves but
it does look like his reflection of his
reflection on the far right does turn
his head a little independently of how
steven turns his head then steve
national gallery while production was in
budapest and last week the museum was a
budapest museum this is actually
london's trafalgar square that's
nelson's column to the left with the
lions the double-decker bus that passes
is an ad for made chandeliers the verona
light another shakespeare reference to
romeo and juliet
where in the most famous scene romeo
compares juliet to the sun his verona
light and begs her to kill the envious
moon in the shakespeare's canon romeo
reunites with his juliet in hopes to end
his toxic moon entity as he enters the
museum the camera till
upside down
that's my favorite shot last episode
when we thought we were right side up
looking at a puddle until a leaf proved
that we were actually upside down all of
it showing how steven's self-perception
is actually illusory in jb's security
arena several cameras are pointed at the
sarcophagus that steven showed the girl
last episode and beside that there is a
qr code on the wall that actually links
to a digital copy of werewolf by night
number 32 which was the first comic
appearance of the moon knight character
that's that's really crazy it shows up
this episode on the number 43 locker at
the storage facility except now marvel
updated the link so that it takes you to
werewolf finite number 33. so i'm
guessing we're gonna see these qr codes
in many episodes throughout the season
and they'll just update it with new
issues each week
i kind of reacted sean i caught that
john
never mistake a well-placed qr code for
anything but advertising
john
only the most important details of the
ones that i get
this is my show i'm the king of this
show did you ever scan it i did
i did had a lot of free time in your
hands
huh
that's a scam codes yeah man after the
show
uh-huh and then i definitely read the
whole thing in one sitting because all i
got is time baby
and uh i think i just put together that
steven's fish's name of gus might be
short for sarcophagus they watch
backpacks
i know
it's just steven reacting to nothing now
fight club has been mentioned as an
influence and this seems like a nod at
the scene of fight club where edward
norton's character fights tyler durden
but later on security footage shows him
hitting himself but if you look closely
at this footage john hasn't seen fight
club first time reacting to that scene
no noise on the screen and if you
compare this last episode that was right
when the jackal hit that surface so
while the jackal is invisible to
everyone else something caused that
static stephen says okay cool
completely it's not all in his head like
ghosts caught on camera yes referencing
the hound of the baskervilles the third
of the four sherlock holmes novels
written by sir arthur conan doyle yeah
dog plaguing an estate was actually
really an inheritance scheme similar to
the hound that chases steve in this
episode if you think about it really
boils down to inheritance scheme arthur
harrow having issues with conscious for
choosing mark spektor as an avatar and
mark spector not wanting the beneficiary
of these abilities to pass on to his
wife and the footage ends with mark
confidently stepping out and staring
directly at the camera as if knowing
steven the next day would review this
footage that's not me
i do have a question about that
um
why would uh mark spectre not try to
wipe the footage
and why did he take the time to redo his
hair a little bit just to leave that
little message there i ain't gonna bore
that it's hollywood okay it's hollywood
magic movie me everyone has great hair
and women to wake up in hospitals with
perfect makeup
to me it was like what did he want to
wipe this footage because it's only
gonna make things more complicated for
whichever form of his is discovered and
i don't think his secret plan is to get
stephen fired from the museum so he can
come on in he's you know like he wants
to control the body so yeah i get where
you're coming from the desk in the hr
office again gives us a clean reflection
of steven the hr manager offers therapy
this particular group of doctors has a
long-standing relationship with us but
the fact that he doesn't get the police
involved but then some cops who do get
involved these detectives end up being
part of harrow's cult makes me wonder if
this hr rep is also part of that cult as
well because he says you're not alone
yes that's like part of the problem in
there yes you're not alone it's a
special threat to stephen we're always
watching for the greater good
with the doctor which could be a nod to
hero's emmett assessment which does
evoke the scientology auditing process
mt also pointed out on inside marvel
that the pamphlet is also covered with a
logo of a green crescent moon shape
which just could be a sign that even
kanju and his possession could all be
part of steven's mental health delusions
stephen is forced to give up fascinating
it has happened he never committed a
memory or shadowing how this episode
ends with stephen surrendering his
steven identity to his mark specter
identity because steven identity crawley
again his homeless friend from the
comics never moves a muscle until
stephen hugs him and crawley side eyes
him just a little example of something
tricky happening just outside of
steven's perception i do wonder hey like
how much of this actually is in his head
what if we're living in some type of
world created and b
i still think he's interacting with mark
spector too you mean crawl he is yeah
yeah yeah i would think so so he's got
to just like keep it real tight-lipped
around steve or maybe he's always like
this guy is weird yeah
yeah i just gotta wait until he leaves
don't engage him
or maybe jake lockley knows him
who's jake lockley
cab driver persona maybe he gives him
rides home or something like that
now in addition to the qr code detail
the locker number 43 could be a nod to
moon knight number 43 in which moon
knight faces seth falcon a villain who
drains a person's life similar to the
way arthur harrow does alcohol train
storage unit are reflective but
noticeably cloudier than the other
reflective surfaces we've seen on the
show maybe a safeguard put in place by
mark so that when he was in this room he
wouldn't accidentally see steven's eyes
and accidentally surrender control back
to him steven finds mark's pistol in
stacks of foreign currency the red 100
notes are chinese yuan making me wonder
what reason mark might have needed to go
to china or interact with chinese
office deal with the ten rings mark's
american passport listings chinese
hookers
oscar isaac's real life birthday is
march 9th for the year 1979 because
hollywood subtracts eight years for men
but then adds 16 for women rightfully so
throw them
got his passport during the blip which
started in may 2018 of the mcu timeline
confirming that mark was not dusted
during those fights interesting debunked
what if mark wasn't dusted but one of
the personalities was dusted
is that possible i want a whole episode
dissecting the the logistics of how that
would work does a piece of his brain
disappear this show's kind of toying
with the rules a little bit i've like
peeked through a lot of moon night
comics but there's only one run i
actually finished which was the lemire
smaller and that's the only run i
actually completed there mark spector's
mr knight but here steven is the one who
dons mr knight it really does
distinguish them as different people so
i wonder what the rules are going to be
here how differentiated they'd be here
maybe it could be i could see them doing
something to that effect you laughed at
me and i took it personal i can dish it
i can't take it i want to see your
timeline most of these shows have had
one sequence where it's like oh mid blip
so hey maybe we'll see that stephen
finds the golden scarab which hovers
over his palm
to the nose yeah this compass would
presumably point towards experiences
southeast of the uk worth noting that
this would also be the general compass
heading for mecca which muslims around
the world pray in the direction of
throughout the day in this case the
scarab also those aren't americans
reflections
i don't care
how bloody handsome you are
tell me what it is you are yeah gotta
love the meta joke for oscar isaac there
before stephen he sees handsomeness as a
factor of confidence something he
doesn't have thus he's unable to see his
own good looks mark explains i serve
can't you
i'm his avatar
which means you are too
sort of
we
protect the vulnerable
and deliver conscious
justice to those who hurt them mark
pauses before using the word justice
the answer is comparison between
conscious justice after damage was done
between that and on its judgment before
any sins were committed a distinction
that stephen later levies against hero
stephen looks at the gun or he doesn't
feel it's real justice let me finish
this and you'll never hear from me again
yikes mark is in the reflective surface
of the pistol too it's very dark to
imagine someone hearing these kinds of
voices when pondering picking up a gun
like steven could be imagining one way
to silence mark forever now earlier when
they walked up to this locker the motion
sensor lights of her head slammed on
just setting up this awesome scare with
konchu now flashing in and out of the
lights with louder and louder slams
yeah so the lights alone represent the
demon like the barrels and jaws
representing the shark this also works
like an inverse of david f sandberg's
amazing lightning short the ghost and
the light instead of the ghost in the
dark stephen gazes up at conscious form
as the layup overhead glows brighter and
brighter and i just love it like a
crescent moon divot and the ridge of his
beak like he's been in some kind of
battle in this ghostly form and then you
can see up into his skull orifices a
ribbed texture interior for our pleasure
because the inside of a lot of skulls
are rarely smooth or sanded down just
little details like this make it more
life-like
the back of his head makes the light
look like a crescent moon
shot of him entering the museum earlier
she says to him you really could have
given me any sign that you were alive
yeah throughout this conversation he
sees her through the mirror the people
he speaks to in mirror reflections are
just difficult for him to trust is
legitimate in his flat when layla looks
at gus in the tank mark's reflection
appears in the tank behind hers despite
steven being back at the door showing
how mark is now in a kind of sunken
place trapped in an egyptian themed tank
like gus is way out of your depth
brother you're literally in the depths
of pearl's revealer secrets
modern hebrew novels gonna be a good dad
eric boss circle collection of letters
among hasidic rabbis mark spector is
jewish son of a rabbi something this
series will explore with the jewish
cultural consultant listed in the
credits
the man in the jews shoes
neolithic corpse in the glacier in the
alps it's actually not that far from the
valley where steven woke up last episode
and of course man in the ice we
definitely had another one of those in
the mcu but the book layla picks up is
the collection another steve marceline
deborah de vamore lefleur or the flowers
from the year 1833 the two of them quote
the opening verses from les separae or
the separated marceline deborah valmer
are they declaring war against america
they are those dirty french do not write
i am sad i would like to die out the
beautiful summers without you are the
night without a torch these words
reflect the separation between these two
lovers mark ghosted her wanting to die
out in layla's mind essentially telling
her don't contact me but really without
each other they have been lost in the
darkness earlier in this episode we got
the allusion to this romeo's son making
the moon envious and here's another
literary illusion comparing this
star-crossed lover to a flame in the
night and it's sweet that layla's
favorite poet was stephen's favorite
poet despite him having no other memory
of her and mark even trying to block her
out like mj still wearing peter parker's
broken necklace another example in the
mcu of love persevering through memory
when layla finds a scare oh that's sweet
on the table besides steven a little
gator or a croc statue
ready to devour later
i mean it's not just ahmet i see some
crescent moons back there too
whoa
details and easter eggs breakdown and
look there's a little man underneath
them all you could argue is like mark
yeah hold into the cycles of the moon oh
yeah we could do whatever it was
this is it's the same thing yeah and
blue color palette representing how sad
he feels yeah yeah and you know light
reflects off the moon there are no
actual lights on so all the light in
this room is just reflecting from the
sun like you know moonlight
you sound so stupid
i know eric
you take care of that stuff i'll be over
here
embarrassing then the detectives knock
at the door
they see fitzgerald and jc kennedy here
it's gerald and kennedy interesting
names detectives because it's the middle
name in the surname of the u.s president
john fitzgerald kennedy because these
are probably fake names recognizable to
an american but less so to a brit actor
anne akageri
and david gainley as billy when they
bring in steven run mark's records his
file number begins with 1975. that was
the year moon knight first appeared in
marvel comics and the assigned agent is
nick pepin the real-life production
manager on moon knight and several other
marvel titles love it when they work the
crew names in there the multiverse shows
at least four bodies shot in the heads
at an archaeological dig site in egypt
which seems like this is all being taken
from moon knight comics where raul
bushman murders marlene's
archaeologist's father before mark
becomes moon knight something that may
be the case with layla and her father
oh they are drinking
kool-aid based on their tattoos there's
a tattoo also on the kid with the soccer
ball and her tattoo seems to even move a
bit as she's holding that ball the
soccer ball is unworthy
to see the world we create arrow greets
him it's the future soccer steven grant
of the gift shop
oh god i hate those glass sounds i'm
sorry for the weight
yeah they mixed in sounds of broken
glass and sandals on each of his steps
konshu begs steven to kill hero break
his windpipe but steven ignores him and
kancho kicks the trash bin just a little
thing setting up all the invisible
forces smashing stuff in the climax of
this episode hero takes even on a tour
of this cult commune and chats with
jamila in mandarin
yeah again if you listen to his kick
there's a bit of broken glass mixed in
there as konju watches from the roof his
crescent moon staff frames the street
light above there's no light of the moon
yet showing how konchu is still
powerless at this point in scene inside
bob dylan's every grain of sand plays
once more just like it did in the
opening scene of the series there's some
cult members watching serene nature
footage just classic clockwork orange
style indoctrination there haro
recommends a lentil soup victor's recipe
gracias victor
he's from the yucatan miss
that is very funny hmm victor there is a
victor mancha in the marvel comics aka
victorious cyborg son of mexican mother
marionella mancha and ultron tech who's
part of the runaways ties in with the
age of ultron storyline later kills
vision sun then i don't know if this is
the same victor definitely is
is that how we're doing these breakdowns
though
i'm just going to find a name and go is
there a character marvel comics
maybe it's that is ever do it to me
because i've wanted to see that victor
brought to life for ages so don't tease
me like that you're playing on my
emotions now everyone's always wanted
certain characters to come into the mcu
and for me
it's that guy you said the vic victor
that victory guy
i just love how harrow feeds stephen
these lentils that were grown in their
community garden while using a gardening
metaphor to describe amit's judgment she
tears evil up from the root casting her
judgment before any evil's done
that's why we must resurrect her almost
as if he's saying you're enjoying our
garden trust the gardener but stephen
rightfully counters if army judges
people pre-evil like before the fact
then
isn't she judging an innocent person a
thought can't be evil can it i think
about can it depends
all the time but i wouldn't actually do
it what about a child would she kill a
child for something they might do in 30
years and stephen doesn't buy harrow
comparing kids to diseased limbs needing
an amputation so harrow has to whip out
the big guns yes yes
i'm amit's gift to her first avatar it
contains in a tiny sliver of her pal yes
another reference to ahmed's first
avatar who betrayed her my speculator
could be fero ramat aka kkk i know it
sounds like i'm reaching just watch my
video on that i swear i make a pretty
good case for it i like how throughout
this
memories back away in fear that
projected nature footage now shows a
hummingbird flapping its wings and then
mushrooms sprouting mirroring the
tension of the scene the chaotic
heartbeat of a hummingbird then
exploding into a mushroom cloud plume
layla arrives at the scarab and they
flee as harrow uses the cane to open a
purple crack purple power through which
another jackal arises another example of
glowing purple rifts through dimensions
in the mcu after a spider-man no way
home perhaps the purple glow indicates
the realm between universes what wong
called the dark border between known and
unknown realities and it is from this
realm where these hell beasts are
summoned hero chants
an honest staff those crocodile eyes
glow purple the jackal knocks stephen
out the window this is likely the moment
he loses a scarab considering his jacket
billows up
but steven hits a superhero landing
dressed as a dapper mr knight look taken
directly from warren ellis's 2014 comics
or as mr knight in the comics is really
a clever criminologist detective another
main form of konchu in this series it's
really just the form stephen grant takes
when he tries to summon konchu the suit
is a finely tailored three-piece suit
with a form-fitting mask with stitching
down the center of the face reflecting
steven's fractured identity if i'm not
mistaken there have been some people who
are actually pretty upset by this
version of mr knight here while he his
sarcastic
cracks once in a while mr knight's
actually pretty badass where
stephen grant here is already kind of
like fish out of water goofy character
than mr knight they really make funny
here i
personally don't
mind this version at all i guess i'm not
married to
the comic material but watching it here
i think it just works so well within the
context of the show itself especially to
bounce off of mark spector who is so
serious and his moon knight you take
very serious as well whereas stephen
grant and the way like they they use the
physicality of the kind of suit that it
is where it feels more throwback-y like
if there's something that feels i don't
know stage performer-esque about the
kind of classical vibe of the suit
almost vaudevillian that's the freaking
word i was looking for vodka dillian yes
yeah
so yeah a very vagina feeling and i
really love the way it looks i don't
mind it whatsoever well who's to say he
won't become more of a badass later on
into the show as steven gets more of his
sea legs under him you know become more
fancy
or sharp more capable confident good
looking i like it funny i like it funny
too maybe they'll find a nice middle
ground that makes everyone happy
god john
comic book fans
happy you freaking vodka idiot [ __ ]
malcolm yeah [ __ ] man i like
fantasies and fantasies only
but i love his shoes loafers with these
white wrappings just a little hint of
that mummy linen aesthetic he and mark
argue she said i needed a suit yeah the
ceremonial armor from conscious temple
not psycho colonel sanders i don't know
how only this [ __ ] works yeah i just
like how it responds to that the mark
reflection blinks his glowing eyes
slowly and disappointment layla breaks
the bottle over the jackal's head so
that she can see it with the fluid
that's sticking to him but then the
jackal lifts them both and slams them
against the wall as it does so you can
still see the last of those little
droplets of fluid shaking off from the
motion steven tries to lure it away
he squirty muhammad ali not realizing
that the second half of that line was
his hands can't hit what his eyes don't
see ironic since he is trying to fight
something invisible to everyone else
also worth noting that mark in the
comics had a past as a boxer stephen
instead says
which is a fun nod to the fact that the
mcu already has another stephen with a
ph stephen strange and then after he
hits the jackal he
i did screams which is slaying used in
london that came from immigrants from
caribbean countries yeah basically
meaning what's up or what's going on the
double technologies
the grc reuniting you with your better
half the grc of course is a global
repatriation council the agency
introduces the falcon the winner soldier
that resettles people after the blip
also ironically in this moment steven is
struggling to reconnect with his other
half overhead this bus is coated with
wbn0032 another nod to where was last
night 32 moon knight's first comic
appearance also apparently the one
comics references series is allowed to
have easter eggs for stephen has to
surrender control right blue knight's
ceremonial suit takes over and i love it
beneath those mummy wrappings gold armor
slides out over his
assembly shoulders stitching together of
the suit is just so piecemeal and
tactile you can see each thread snaking
and binding him just reminds me of the
pieces of iron man's armor clinking
together in that original
linen man unsheathes his chest weapons
but she seems to have an unlimited
supply like
slot mark lures the jackal up the
building past the crescent moon which
now glimmers in the background as we saw
last episode the crescent moon shines
when moon knight has the upper hand as
he leaps from rooftop to rooftop in this
thrilling montage that crescent moon
actually gets larger and larger in the
frame symbolizing his growing power he
runs down the tunnel that's really neat
and the surface of the water is messing
up all the tides on earth on this
outdoor altar and retracts his chest
piece in the light of the crescent moon
the two shapes matching each other this
gorgeous shot composition here and
showing how all of this power is coming
from the moon they match each other if
you freeze straight from her courtyard
there is a silhouette of someone
watching in the shadows in the
background might be an onlooker might be
a crew person who got left in frame give
me the watcher stephen
i've always managed to keep a wall
between us but something's changed good
the one who controls the bodies becomes
stronger the reflections help but most
of the time it'll take all your
willpower just to be a fly on the wall
yes so it sounds like to answer harrow's
query from before mark might have
already had dissociative identity
disorder now conscious possession is
making whichever identity is in control
at any moment stronger at keeping the
other identities suppressed mark says we
wouldn't be alive if it weren't for
conscience in my servitude
is the price that i pay so yes it sounds
like they are adapting mark spectre's
origin from the comics that mark was
dying when he came across conscious tomb
and that's when he got possessed but
steven now bolder and angrier as one of
the suppressed voices really gets under
mark's skin
[Music]
yes the church bell tolls remarks mental
break like the bell of a boxing ring
signaling the end of a round another nod
to mark's boxing history like the church
is saying hey break it up break it up
back to your quarter now
detail here if you count the bell chimes
to try to figure out the hour it rings
at least 14 maybe 15 times which is
crazy because it's 3 p.m
ring more than 12. so they may have
doubled up because as we cut in and out
of steven's reflection they could have
done that to show both identities
hearing the first couple chimes i love
how consciousness is among the gargoyles
of the root just blending in with the
surroundings and the shot does not break
from mark's perspective as we then look
up to another rooftop where conscious
suddenly appearing there mid-sentence
and then the camera drifts right back
down to mark where konchu is right
behind him and i love how in the
moonlight now streaming through the tree
you can clearly see how this skull is
actually floating over his body but
those errant hairs connected to his
skull drape downward to make it seem
like there is a connection like a
marionette head defying gravity love
this transition here
dissolving is the falling curtain that
mark had draped over a broken mirror to
hide his reflection since mark is in a
different spot of the room the
reflection is stephen covered in a bed
sheet on the bed his knuckles bloody
this means that steven must have tried
to break out of the state violently and
injured himself now looking a lot like
martin sheen after he cut his hands on
the broken mirror in apocalypse now and
in that cracked mirror
that's a great reference necklace
juice converts juice
the mc
egypt and i just love that this whole
sudden transition to egypt took us here
while we were in mark's perspective
confirming that konchu backseats his
avatar whoever is at the wheel steven
ormark and that this avatar like us is
really just along for the ride now over
the credits please travel so easily i'm
a luke by ahmed saad featuring inaba
double zuch awesome egyptian jammer to
end this episode and the final shot of
the credits actually changes from last
episode before it was an amazing shot of
moon knight's footed ceremonial warrior
attire now it is mr knight again the
best way to support us is to check out
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
instagram and twitter ea boss follow new
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
cool way to go eric boss voss
oh cool how did she travel so much
um
bus
took a bus to egypt yep just took a bus
all the way down through africa
off screen
you can you have to go through africa
uh-huh egypt is a part of africa i'm
told i haven't ever actually looked at
the map i thought you have to cut
through michigan mm-hmm yeah yeah i mean
like because of the flight patterns
you'll fly to michigan then you'll fly
to south america
then you'll fly to japan and then
eventually you'll go back to uh england
again and then to egypt
i think is how
a regular it flights egypt i'm pretty
sure he's just right next to detroit i
i'm you know what i'm going to defer to
you on all matters of geology geography
and etc you know
you're a much more world weary guy what
is this gynecology
what doesn't it not have to do with all
of us
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below if you have a gynecologist
hey let's do a patron
flev
flavius doran dude i know you're a big
marvel fan and i was thinking who
of all the patrons here would be the
right kind of stand-in for steven grant
type and that will be you my friend i
could totally because slav hey he's got
an unflappable good nature but i feel
like you know flev needs a little dose
of adventure and injected
um you know because uh phlev and i we've
hung out on multiple occasions you know
when i'm doing my living statue shifts
in the public park
you know in romania where flev lives
where i often travel because it's also
right next to detroit and so you know
he's told me a lot about his life
confided many things in me and i don't
even let him know basically uh you know
that he just had this date didn't go
very well he was two days late for it it
was crazy plus he lost his job at the
night in the museum directed by sean
levy
levy
it doesn't matter because flev
is a wonderful human being and anyone
would be lucky to go out for a steak
dinner with you buddy i would
you always know what to comment to make
me feel good so yeah yeah
be well flev
thanks for answering my questions
[Music]